hey guys I'm Ilana oh charl on azad and
welcome to my channel today you are
watching a video of my impressions of
the xbox and bethesda III 2015 press
conferences so I'm gonna try and keep
this short and sweet starting with doom
I thought the term looked quite generic
got rid of the kind of doom aesthetic
even but it's hard to call something
generic when the reason it's generic is
because everything copied it but there's
still definitely pressure on doomed to
be different to every game that has
copied it and I didn't really see that
in the gameplay that we saw I was
frankly kind of bored I think that
people who played the older doom games
will like this but almost no one else is
going to care then I was dishonored to
which was leaked so the announcement
didn't mean that much to me I thought
the world looked totally gorgeous and
emily is an optional protagonist you can
choose between male or female being
Emmaline coho and I think that that is
really really sweet and then there was
fallout 4 oh my god it started off with
this like sims I'll character creation
menu which i think is the best looking
character creation menu we've seen yet
in a pathetic game and of course you can
play as a female it was rumored that you
wouldn't be able to because there's
voice acting in it but that's ridiculous
it's the fez death I also think that the
gameplay that we saw at e3 looked a lot
better graphically than the reveal
trailer I honestly don't catching much
about graphics but I'm really happy that
fallout 4 doesn't have that weird like
grey green wash on everything that
fallout 3 had it looks much prettier and
the dog is a companion which we already
kind of knew but it kind of seems like
the dog is the only companion in this
one unless you can have to but it
definitely seems like the dog is
compulsory and then they announced
pitboy collector's edition which I've
already pre-ordered it is literally a
pip-boy the same one that we saw in the
gameplay that fits on your arm and you
put your phone in it you can go through
the pit point menu on a smartphone app
that they're developing and I oh my god
then they discuss a settlement thing
which is basically a Minecraft and
fallout does seem like this pixel so I
think this looks really cool it's
basically a feature where you get to
build your own house but maybe also
build a kind of colony for other people
but it looks like it's very customizable
things have to run on power kind of
similar to redstone in Minecraft and I
feel like that looks really exciting and
then there's
weapon and armor modification which just
had so much that I just don't even know
how they fit so much into one game one
of the power armor options seem like it
had a jetpack I'm so excited about it
and it's coming out in November 2015 and
the reveal was everything that I wanted
I'm so so happy at the end of that press
conference everyone who attended in
person also got given these the little
vinyl figures from some of the games
that was shown and I was going to making
a video unboxing these but I decided I'm
actually not going to i'm just going to
keep them and it's partly because it
says this on the back i want to i want
to keep these in the box the first time
ever as a collector I've never wanted to
do this before but you know box is nice
so next up with Xbox I'm trying to get
through this so quickly because i'm so
tired and I have to go to Sony really
soon I'm sorry for rushing we saw a
little bit about halo 5 Guardians didn't
really get to see much about the story
which is what I was really interested in
but hey Nathan Fillion is in it which is
great and let's just jump forward to
when they announced that the xbox one is
going to be backwards compatible oh my
god I had no idea that announcement was
coming I can't believe that that didn't
leak that's I'm so happy about that my
xbox 360 is kind of dying and it's
really slow and doesn't connect to the
internet anymore so being able to play
them all on my xbox one I'm happy that
those games that i love have a longer
lifespan now then there was a little
more fallout 4 news in the xbox
conference where they announced that
mods fallout 4 from pc can be
transferred to the xbox one so we don't
know exactly how this works at this
point or even if it's an xbox only thing
it could also be a sony thing but I feel
like consoles probably can't handle all
of the same mods that pc can so i'm not
sure exactly how they're going to manage
that but i think it's awesome that
they're doing that then they had a
trailer for dark souls 3 which looks
very pretty but we didn't really see
much of it and at that point it was like
halfway through and I was shocked about
how many video games we'd seen and the
fact that none of them will call of duty
we saw
little bit more of the division as well
which i'm actually at this point very
sick of seeing trailers for it's always
just the same rehash crap that I just
don't care about anymore and we saw some
of Rainbow six siege which on the other
hand I do care about because rainbow six
vegas and vegas to our fantastic games
which are apparently coming free with
the xbox one version of Rainbow six
siege and then we had two later which
was beautiful it was so pretty it looks
like it's gonna play very very similar
to its predecessor but more lens flare I
also really like that it's mostly in ice
which is probably the most drastic
change that we saw between it and the
previous game and I kind of hope that
there will be you know the threat of
freezing to death and some survival and
elements in there that cater to you
trying to resist the cold then they
announce a rare replay which is a bunch
of r a games that run the 64 that are we
releasing on xbox one which i'm very
happy about i do find it a little odd
things i'm most excited about from this
entire conference bits whether telling
me i can play video games that i already
own but like on a new console so many
good games in there that i'm very happy
to be able to play again i hope that i
still enjoy them as much now because
it's hard for me to go back and play
them on the 64 when i'm used to modern
gaming controls because that kinda hard
to play and then there was hololens
where they showed us how you can
interact with minecraft using the
hololens by projecting someone's
minecraft world onto a table and then
interacting with it hololens is so
freaking cool i wonder how it'll
function when it actually gets to
consumers but it's just such a sweet
looking thing what's next Gears of War
they announce a release it gives the one
including multiplayer which I'm happy
about I played a lot of Gears of War One
multiplayer but then they showed the new
gears which to me largely looks exactly
the same as the others but I didn't play
judgment and haven't played gears and
Wilson's three came out which was like a
pretty long time ago now so I will
plague is full but I really want to find
out more information about it at this
point and that was it for both of the
conferences I preferred Bethesda to xbox
feel like they had like a no bull crap
approach and just really gave us lots of
games and lots of information xbox had
some stuff that I didn't really care
about but the highlights of me as I said
were rare replay and the backwards
compatibility compatibility
compatibility and I have also seen EA
but I'm not going to fit that into this
video and I haven't seen you reserved
because I'm here recording this and then
play stations are just about to start so
I think that I'll try and make a video
for the next three as well but I hope
you guys enjoyed this video this is kind
of brief impressions of all the stuff
that's been announced at e3 press
conferences imma wanna thank you for
watching and I will see you soon bye